they've been so many King Arthur movies
to come what makes this film different I
mean really Guy Ritchie's sensibility I
mean he's so fresh and young and cool
and like it has like a rock-and-roll
punk rock directing style it's very
seldom been seen in historical epic type
of movies so like you know the Arthurian
legend through the prism of Guy Ritchie
just feels like unlike anything you've
seen before so in this film able to meet
the man behind the legend of King Arthur
well it's important to you to be meet
that and not so noble King Arthur knows
what's not so interesting unless it has
context and I think we can relate to
struggle story to me has to be about the
struggle and this really personifies I
suppose the the legend personifies that
struggle the rise from the gutter to the
throne I can afflict the legend of King
Arthur's magical swarn everybody gets
old
what is your Excalibur like what's that
thing that gives you on caning strength
what give me strength
mostly hard to do with having an impact
on a socially impact on somebody's life
that's empowering the opportunity to
give your characters in your films
nicknames what's that all about
all subcultures see there reside there
seems to be no such thing as a
straightforward Christian name Australia
down twist on a Monica so I mean who
doesn't like a Monica with some flavor
in it she used to call me um the movie
star Saturday I movie star
and a couple of other nicknames that are
not appropriate for television have come
on there but now mainly he called me
movie star which was you know I became
good friends with them during this and
he's very very good friends with them
with David Beckham also so David Beckham
a football star and not many stars two
pals who would you give that friend
nickname maybe bruiser
[Music]
okay
[Music]